in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Brandon
and kanesha are with us hey guys how are
you how are you welcome welcome where
you guys from Mississippi Tupelo
Mississippi I love it fun welcome to
Nashville and here to do a debt-free
scream yes sir
I love it how much have you guys paid
off thirty-one thousand I love it good
good and how long did that take you 20
months and making what kind of range of
income during that time 60,000 60,000 a
year what do you guys do for a living
I'm a nurse truck driver all right cool
very cool what kind of debt was the
thirty one thousand there's a little bit
of everything
credit cards personal loans vehicles
that's about it yeah what happened two
years ago what was the wake-up call that
made you decide you're gonna change your
life and get out of debt my parents they
um they did your plan and I guess they
we was crying too then we never had any
money to do anything so they set us down
and they said you know this is what you
need to do and they paid for us to go
through the financial piece and here we
are today how'd you take to that Brandon
when your father-in-law something goes
hey look here I wasn't sure about it at
first I wouldn't man but we're glad we
listened yeah yeah it helped a lot
especially when you don't think it's
gonna happen until that that bought the
snowball starts going and then it it's
really enthused and then it does work
yeah very cool very fun
well what great parents that love you
enough to kind of not put up with your
whining huh that's right that's fun very
fun so what was the hardest debt for you
all to pay off what was the one thing
that when you paid it off man now I'm
glad that one's gone the vehicle problem
yeah yeah yeah once you get rid of that
when you think it's like a I think we
can do this we see light at the end of
the tunnel we can do it yeah I guess the
hardest part is the last two are the
last big one it you've been rolling down
the hill quick with a smaller ones and
then you get to this big arena we're
never gonna finish it yeah yeah yeah but
I guess you just get enough momentum you
keep going that's right
very cool very cool how's it feel to not
have any payments oh it's great
therefore it's great how long have you
guys been married we just celebrated our
fifth anniversary okay alright and so
almost two years of the five years
you've been working on this yeah good so
when people find out you've paid off
$31,000 in debt and I ask how did you do
that what do you tell them the secret is
to get out of that the budget yeah and
stick into the budget yeah yeah most
people they think you're crazy they
think you got to be rich to do this plan
we're just average people when we set
out for ago when we did it yeah 20
months later you're here guys right
Danny thing right here in the lobby yeah
I love it very cool what was the hardest
part for you guys overall probably the
social life we're giving up everything
we're really big and in church and
everybody wants to go eat and all your
friends want to go eat and we say well
we better not this time we're just gonna
go home and I'm gonna cook and then
whenever you do do something there
they're like did they approve of that to
give Dave a call for I can't come out
it's funny I love it well
congratulations you two
very proud of you thank you you feel
good yes I feel like you can do anything
now right I love it all right Brandon
and kanesha from Tupelo Mississippi
$31,000 paid off in 20 months making
$60,000 a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream ready 1 2 3
weird
great job you guys
great job love it love it love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind